Let's go next to our caller from the two four
eight area code.
Who's calling today from two four eight?
Hi, Espace from Michigan.
Hey.
What's going on?
Hey, first of all, I love your show.
I started watching it, listening to it about
a year ago.
Thank you.
I just want to say that.
So I have two questions.
One was related to your previous callers,
the Black Lives Movement.
Back when it first started happened.
George Floyd was killed.
I think the public, the majority of the public
had their support in terms of police reform.
Now it seems like it's, you know, turning
into a very vague and.
Doesn't really have a direction or specifics
of what the people want.
And I don't know if that's going to be good
for the Democrats, especially coming into
November.
In terms of getting rid of police or defending
all police and things like that, I was worrying
if you can comment on that second question.
Yesterday, Biden at some event.
Made a statement that he would reverse most
of Trump's tax cuts.
Yeah.
How how much do you think that'll affect the
moderates in terms of their support for Biden?
Because I know they're probably more conservative
in terms of tax.
I mean, no, nobody wants more taxes to pay
more taxes.
Biden, you know, he's been doing great in
the polls nationally.
And most states, especially, you know, the
swing states even I think today Texas, he's
even with Trump.
But do you think making any comments about
reversing tax cuts would be bad for him?
I mean, he's just staying.
Why?
He's been doing great in the polls, just doing
nothing.
But do you think that helps or hurts him?
I think that his comment about the tax cuts
is not going to have a big impact.
I think that right now, really what you have
is a referendum on corona virus, a referendum
on the economy as a result of corona virus,
a referendum on Trump's reaction to the protests,
which has been abysmal, and a referendum essentially
on Trump as the laughing stock around the
world that many believe him to be.
So listen, Joe Biden has made it clear like
nothing is going to substantively change for
the privileged in the United States under
Joe Biden.
So he'll reverse that.
Trump's tack trump tax cuts or let certain
provisions expire.
The very rich will pay a few points more.
But again, nothing will fundamentally change.
It's these are really just slight tweaks.
So I think at this point, because this is
such a referendum on Trump, I don't think
that the tax cut comment is really going to
meet be a huge, different difference maker.
We'll see.
As the new polls come out in the next seven
to 10 days.
Now, in terms of Black Lives Matter.
I don't believe that what's going on with
Black Lives Matter is going to hurt Democrats
in November at all.
I think, as you pointed out from the beginning,
on the main issue that re focused attention
on Black Lives Matter right now, which were
the protests that started after the death
of George Floyd.
Overwhelming support for police reform, reform,
support for Black Lives Matter itself is way
up compared to where it was, you know, two
months ago or just before the start of this.
I think really the only risk is what we've
seen Republicans already try to do, which
is to couch the protesters as overwhelmingly
violent or criminal.
And it's mostly failed.
I mean, like Trump and Kaylee McInerney, you
know, they keep pushing it.
But I think people pretty much know at this
point that protesters are protesting and that's
the majority of what's going on.
And then other than that, you have other people
who are participating and doing bad acts,
but they're really not representative of the
movement.
So, no, I don't think it's going to hurt Democrats
in November.
OK, yeah, that makes sense.
Oh, one last thing.
And I've taken up a lot of time, but when
do you think Biden will announce a V.P.?
I think it's it should should be obvious that
it's Kamala Harris.
But, you know, I think she would be the best
bet.
But would he wait until the you know, until
what's it called until the convention?
Yeah.
He said it'll be around.
He's gonna announce around August 1st is what
he said.
So I would expect, you know, that's a month
away.
I would expect that will be roughly around
that time.
All right.
Let's go to a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up, because
I will go right back to the phones right after
this short break.